hi welcome to biology professor today we
are talking about neuron structure
neurons are the core style of the
nervous system they are responsible for
transmitting electrical or
electrochemical signals to other cells
the most well known types of neurons are
sensory neurons and motor neurons these
are the cells that when you touch a
hotplate they transmit the signal to
your brain that Hanna talked these are
also the neurons that allow you to move
your arms around so let's look at their
structure here's an example of a neuron
here we have the nucleus in black and
the soma or cell body and you can see
that branching out of one side of the
soma are multiple dendrites these are
like fingers they allow the neuron to
reach out into its environment
and receive signals from other cells
these signals then propagate down what
is called an axon if we come over here
to look at an axon in more depth you'll
see that the axon almost looks like
beads on a string here the beads are
myelin sheaths so this is when the
compound myelin is wrapped around the
membrane of the axon and it acts as an
insulator it allows the chemical or the
electrical signal to propagate down the
axon from node to node so in between the
myelin sheaths we see the nodes of
ranvier they're also called unmyelinated
gaps and the electrical signal is being
able to hop from node to node as it goes
down the axon eventually reaching
synaptic knobs
these synaptic knobs are able to reach
out and connect with other dendrites
for example I've drawn another neuron
here but these synaptic knobs can reach
out to dendrites of multiple surrounding
neurons so that the original signal that
this neuron received gets propagated to
other nearby neurons and that's
basically how the nervous system makes
things happen in your body